many people would think tight lacing
squeezing a waste into a corset is an
extreme act but over the ages people
have squeezed stretched even mutilated
their bodies for their cultural group in
Thailand the heavy brass neck rings of
the Cayenne long neck women are
considered a thing of beauty in a
tradition lasting centuries tallness is
revered in China so much so that some
people undergo surgery to break and
stretch their legs just to be an inch or
two taller in recent times the corset
has experienced a resurgence not just as
a costume piece popularized by artists
like Madonna but also as a garment
associated with sexual expression and
fetishism and not the sole domain of
women Stewart trench Browne not only
makes corsets he wears them insisting
the offer far more than just figure
enhancement sizing Nicole's it's
brilliant again he's like being held in
a giant hand if you if you're a couple
and you're both wearing a corset then
it's pretty amazing Stewart knows that
some couples who become locked together
after engaging in sex while corseted in
extreme cases the fire brigade is being
cooled to actually separate them Stewart
his wife Constance and there are
seamstress Karen see corseting is a way
of life attending special events that
propel them into a Victorian world